it's been nearly a week since ivana's
untimely passing at the age of 73 she
died from blunt impact injuries to her
torso but her death was ruled accidental
and today family including her
ex-husband former president donald trump
and friends said their final goodbyes
ivana's three children donald jr ivanka
and eric trump arrived with their
families to eulogize their mother at the
invitation-only event ex-donald trump
was in attendance with wife melania amid
heavy security
the celebration of life at new york's
saint vincent ferrer church was just
blocks away from ivana's home of almost
50 years it's where she passed away on
thursday after falling down these stairs
ivana gave us an exclusive tour in 2005.
this house i bought it about 30 years
ago for very little money and there was
absolutely nothing the staircase was in
here that was that ivana and donald
divorced in 1992 she walked away with an
over 14 million dollar settlement that
inspired her famous the first wives club
cameo remember
what don't get mad get everything
the former model turned author and
business mogul remained close with her
ex donald was there with our e.t cameras
when ivana married her fourth husband
rosano rubicondi in 2008. he was 23
years her junior rubicondi passed away
eight months ago i pronounced them
husband and wife
but through it all ivana told us her
kids were always her priority never ever
talk badly about about about your spouse
because it does reflect on them you know
they are part of him as much they are
part of you
so you have to always talk nicely it
doesn't matter how how bad you feel or
you could strengthen the person at that
minute
how do i want to be known as a good
person good mother
achiever grammar care or combination of
all of it
[Music]